there is now a battle brewing on the the
sexual revolutionary left
between the bisexuals
and the pan-sexuals what does a pan say
i'm you know being italian i've often
considered myself a pansexual
you get some nice fatty meats frying up
in there oh man that gets
that gets my motor running baby there
are very few no
that's not what it it's not sexual
attraction
to pans and the delicious foods in them
it is
sexual attraction i guess to just
everything
or the sexual identity involving just
everything it's very vague
and this is is offensive to bisexual
people
who actually believe that there is a
gender dichotomy right there's
men and women and those are the two
things there's not more than two things
so a brilliant sexual philosopher
and girl with green hair and tattoos and
piercings and things
and apparently a paper clip through her
nose
came out and explained this issue guess
what
my patience is run out pansexuality is
not inherently biphobic they are both
valid sexualities both of them and while
yes i have seen pansexual people use
that label for questionable reasons
they pretty quickly get it once you
explain things to them
they do and not only that but do you
know who likes to use specific or micro
labels
neurodivergent people sometimes we just
have to do whatever we can to feel safe
and comfortable
and using a more specific label can be
our outlet for that
if you took all that energy you spend
calling people biphobic
and saying they're performing by erasure
and just educated them
there would be less biphobia there would
be less by erasure
because you've explained it and people
will know the difference
i have had it with you guys jesus
okay i've only got a couple minutes here
and i've got to process that and try to
explain it
she's obviously wrong about everything
here but i think what she's trying to
say is that
the pansexual people and the bisexual
people have totally different views of
the word they're completely incompatible
and contradictory
but actually that's not a problem
because we're going to tolerate all of
these things
and we're going to add another
complication here that neurodivergent
people which is i believe it's a
euphemism for
people with autism i could be wrong but
i it refers to people who have
sort of quirky uh ways of seeing the
world
i believe that's what it means so they
actually prefer
the specificity so that's you got to be
tolerant of that too
and if we just have education then we'll
all understand but the problem is you
can't
education is not going to solve this
problem of of incompatible
visions right the the law of
non-contradiction you can't
simultaneously hold views
coherently that contradict one another
so
it doesn't solve the problem but she's
she's very exasperated i mean frankly
there's no difference between what this
girl is doing and what john oliver does
or what jon stewart did right they would
just
they would say some stupid liberal
talking point but then they would just
scream an expletive
they'd say you know we need to radically
redefine marriage
or whatever the babies aren't babies and
it's the current year and then they
would just scream like
f you know come on what the f or
whatever and that was supposed to
substitute for an argument
in the spirit of pride month i want you
to know i am i'm really proud
i know pride goes before destruction and
a haughty spirit before fall i am proud
though
of this youtube channel and all you
people who have subscribed
that's so great if you haven't
subscribed yet ring the bell subscribe
get the notifications head on over also
to the audio podcast
apple podcast google play spotify
stitcher i don't know where myspace
zanga live journal subscribe there too
please leave a five star review we'll
see you next time